in today's digital age where our lives
are closely connected with technology
cyber security has emerged as very
important concern the ever evolving
landscape of cyber threats requires
professionals who are very well vered in
the Ines of cyber Securities with 2024
fast approaching it's essential to
identify the best cyber security
specializations or certifications that
will equip you to tackle the challenges
for tomorrow in this video on which
cyber security specialization is best in
2024 we will discuss some best
certifications or specializations that
will pave your way to cyber security
career in this video we will cover why
cyber security specializations are
important after that we will cover
certifications like cissp CompTIA
Security Plus cisa cism sscp and CH but
before we begin with these
specializations make sure to subscribe
to our YouTube channel and press the
Bell icon to never miss an update from
Simply learn all right so let's move on
with the first topic that is why cyber
security specializations are important
so cyber security specializations or
certifications are like your digital
armor they are essential because they
teach you how to protect your online
World from the bad guys it's like having
a superp power to keep your information
safe in the world where everything is
connected to the internet like your
phones computers and even your fridge
bad people can try to steal your secrets
these specializations and certifications
are your Shield making you a digital
hero who can stop the villains and keep
your data safe so they are not just
important they are your ticket to
becoming a cyber security superhero so
now let's have a look at the best
specializations of cyber security first
one is certified information system
security professional that is
cissp so the cisp certification is
widely recognized as a premier
certification in the field of
information security it covers a broad
range of topics including security and
risk management asset security security
engineering communication and network
security other topics include security
assessment testing Etc cissp holders
possess a deep understanding of these
domains making them valuable assets in
protecting organizations from cyber
threats the CIS SSP certification is
highly regarded due to its rigorous
requirements experience prerequisites
and adherence to a code of ethics
ensuring professionals with this
certifications are well-rounded and
trustworthy so this was about cissp now
let's have a look at the next
certification so the next certification
is CompTIA Security Plus so the CompTIA
Security Plus certification is an
entry-level certification that provides
a solid foundation in cyber security
principles and practices it covers
topics such as network security threats
and vulnerabilities identity management
Access Control cryptography and risk
management this certification is highly
regarded for the vendor neutral approach
making it applicable across different
technology platforms it is an excellent
starting point for individuals looking
to enter the cyber security field or
enhance their knowledge in information
security the Security Plus certification
is recognized globally and is often a
prerequisite for more advanced
certification making it a valuable
stepping stone in one's cyber security
career also if you want to become a
cyber Security Professionals then
consider Advanced executive program in
cyber security by simply learn this
Advanced executive program in cyber
security will help you develop expertise
in defensive cyber security application
security malware analysis ethical
hacking Etc in partnership with triple
ID Bangalore and npci the cyber security
program provides you with the deep
understanding needed to sport the
opportunities for disruption in the
cyber security industry so what are you
waiting for androll now get certified
and get ahead so this was about the
CompTIA Security Plus certification next
best certification on the list is
certified information system auditor
that is cisa the cisa certification is
specially designed for professional
involved in auditing controlling and
monitoring Information Systems it
focuses on accessing vulnerabilities and
ensuring compliance with regularity
standards cisa holders possess expertise
in auditing processes it governance
systems and infrastructure life cycle
management and information systems this
certification is highly regarded for its
emphasis on risk management and its
alignment with International auditing
standards CIS certified professionals
are in high demand as they provide
Assurance to organizations that their
information systems are secure reliable
and compliant so this was about cisa
that is certified information system
auditor now coming to the next
certification which is cism that is
certified information security manager
so the cism is tailored certification
for professionals responsible for
managing designing and overseeing an
Enterprise information security program
it covers four domains information
security governance risk management
information security program development
and management and information security
Incident Management cism holders possess
a comprehensive understanding of these
domains enabling them to align
information security with businesses
goals and objectives effectively this
certification is highly regarded that
its focus on strategic management and
its emphasis on the relationship between
information security and business
success cism certified professionals are
sought after for their ability to
establish and manage an organization's
information security program effectively
so this was about cism certification now
let's have a look at the next
certification which is sscp system
security certified practitioner the scsp
certification is designed for
professionals involved in the Hands-On
implement mentation and operation of
information security systems it covers
topics such as access controls security
operations and administration risk
identification and mitigation incident
response and
cryptography scsp holders possess
practical Knowledge and Skills in
various areas of information security
making them valuable Assets in
implementing and maintaining security
systems this certification is highly
regarded for its emphasis on technical
expertise and its alignment with the
industry best practices sscp certified
professional
are sought after for their ability to
apply security controls and counter
measures to protect organizations from
evolving threats so this was about sscp
now the next certification is C that is
certified ethical hacker so the
certified ethical hacker certification
offered by EC council is a highly
respected certification in the field of
cyber security it focuses on training
individuals to think and act like
malicious hackers to identify
vulnerabilities and weaknesses the CES
certification covers topics such as
footprinting and scanning networks
enumeration system hacking malware
threats social engineering and more this
certification equips professionals with
the skills and knowledge needed to
access and strengthen an organization
security posture with its emphasis on
ethical hacking the C certification
plays a crucial role in helping
organizations proactively defend against
cyber threats and Safeguard their
critical assets
so if you want to prepare for all these
specializations then you can opt for
simply learns cyber security expert
Masters program the cyber security
expert Masters program will equip you
with the skills needed to become an
expert in the rapidly growing domain you
will learn comprehensive approaches to
protecting your infrastructure including
securing data and information running
risk analysis and mitigation
architecturing cloud-based security
achieving compliance and much more with
this best-in-class program this
certification will equip you with the
skills that entail industry-leading
certifications like coma Security Plus C
cism cissp and
ccsp androll now the link is in the
description
box so the certifications that we have
covered in this video are considered the
best due to the comprehensive coverage
of essential cyber security domains
their recognition in industry and their
alignment with industry standards and
best practices they provide
professionals with the knowledge skills
credibility needed to excel in the field
of information security and contribute
to the protection of organizations from
cyber
threats all right guys with that we have
come to the end of this video If you
like this video please give it a thumbs
up I hope it really helped you all
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here